hello everybody Welcome to AI the future
of us this is a podcast Style video
series that explores the ways in which
AI is shaping our future and how we can
prepare ourselves for the changes that
lie ahead I'm your host Priyanka regarya
and today we are joined by Paige Billy
who is a product lead for generative AI
models at Google thank you for being
here Paige absolutely thank you for
having me amazing well let's Dive Right
In I am so excited to uh just explain
our viewers today your background and
your expertise in AI I've been watching
you for quite some time but
um I think I think you should go through
an introduction
absolutely so uh I've been doing it AI
for quite a while back before it was
cool
um I started off as a machine learning
engineer and a data scientist was doing
that for a bit over a decade and then
transitioned
um to developer advocacy and product
just a few years ago I'm a boomerang
back to alphabet so I'm currently
working within Google research helping
bring generative models to all of the
product surfaces that we have in
alphabet particularly with the focus on
machine learning for software
development and while I was gone from
alphabet during the pandemic I worked at
GitHub as as one of their product leads
for machine learning and for ML Ops so
it was really exciting to see how the
industry has changed especially in the
last couple of years and I'm really
jazzed to talk to you too about some of
the upcoming things that we've been
working on together to get released out
to users from Google
that is amazing so with that background
it definitely leads me into the impact
of AI on developers and development in
general what are your thoughts about
that
absolutely so so the software
development field it feels like every
day there's a new startup being created
for ML for code generation or ml for
code explanation lots of these kind of
interloop developer activities and when
I say inner loop I mean uh kind of the
process of building software within your
IDE
but really the most exciting things to
me are are what happens after the
software has been shipped and you can
start asking interesting questions about
how do I make this deployment more
efficient how do I make this code more
concise how do I migrate from one API or
one framework to another so I think
those are the or they always wear the
most tedious bits for me about doing
software development and sort of
maintaining systems over time and I'm
really jazzed in particular about the
potential for AI to take away those more
mundane activities and to make it so
that we can all Focus on kind of the fun
part of the job which is asking
questions creating things and then using
using code to solve problems yeah and
just becoming a lot more productive in
the process right absolutely
um so
if you can think of examples of like
effective use cases of AI for developers
what would one two three examples be
sure so at Google we've been thinking
about this for quite some time like we
have an internal system such that all of
our code is hosted in a monorepo and we
also have Telemetry baked into our
entire software development process so
we understand how Engineers are working
together to to discuss code to write
code going through this code review
process and all of that is really
magical training data for its entire
end-to-end life cycle
so things that we've been able to do
internally include things like you might
have seen uh you know coming from GitHub
co-pilot or some of the other tools
around really nice code completion so
being able to do both single line and
then multi-line code completions that
are really contextualized and sort of
using retrieval techniques as well so
it's a hyper optimized for whatever file
or whatever repo you're working in so as
you're authoring code that makes it uh
that makes you much more efficient much
more productive we've also started
applying machine learning to code review
processes so as uh you know you could
imagine if a reviewer uh you know
requests a change automatically being
able to generate code to support that
change
um and then there's another aspect uh
that there was a paper released recently
from the learning to perf team where you
can identify
um you know bits of code that aren't
necessarily as efficient as they could
be
um and being able to kind of at scale
apply those changes
um and save a lot of money in the
process right right like so so if you
imagine all of Google's data centers and
all of the C plus plus code running in
Google's data centers if you're capable
of finding just one small kind of change
that would impact you know processes
running across multiple multiple systems
um then then you can end up saving
hundreds of thousands of gcus which are
uh you know we refer to them as Google
compute units internally but you can you
can really just think about it in in
terms of the order of millions or
billions of dollars of savings per year
across Google's entire fleet so those
are those are three different categories
both writing code this process of
reviewing code and collaborating with
your peers and then also kind of after
the code has been shipped how do you
make it much more efficient and
performant
though the one thing that also sticks
out to me from the cloud side of things
me being like developing for the cloud
and and building applications in the
cloud
um as a developer in Cloud uh being able
to ask uh code uh code samples for
Google Cloud specific use cases that
would be something that I am really
looking forward to absolutely like being
able to being able to get again these
these kind of context aware
recommendations is really huge
um because you know many of these tools
I think are are trained on uh you know
publicly available source code that may
or may not be fit for purpose for the
kinds of production work that you need
to do and if you can get recommendations
that are hyper optimized with either the
latest apis or
um you know the the kinds of apis that
might be beneficial for working on gcp
um that would be that would be very very
powerful
all right so looking ahead for
developers and AI just in general uh
what do you believe is the most exciting
potential
um applications of AI or even things
that um that are coming out from Google
given you're on the research side and
the model building side I'm excited to
learn a little more about about what's
coming what to look out for and what's
already there that we maybe haven't
looked deeper into
yeah so so that's a great question I
think that you know no one would no one
would challenge the statement that in
the last year it feels like things are
increasing exponentially
um in terms of the in terms of the
capabilities that are supported by these
generative models I think that right now
we're very reliant on language models
and increasingly we're going to be
focused more on on multimodal models um
so you know being able to do things like
drawing a picture of what you would want
a website to be and then automatically
having it uh automatically having it
created for you I think another thing
that I'm I'm really passionate about
myself is tool use and also being able
to to have these uh kind of Agents
navigate websites so you could imagine
going on zillow.com
saying Help me find a two-bedroom
two-bathroom house within Palo Alto
within this budget it and also please
make sure that it has a lot of very
sunny windows and and then just through
looking at kind of the the information
in HTML CSS and JavaScript on the
website a little agent is able to
self-navigate towards uh towards a
subset of the Zillow properties that
meet those requirements which would
require it to understand not just code
to generate code to understand natural
language queries to decompose them into
steps and then also to be able to look
at images of the properties and like see
those characteristics
um so I think I think that's that's
really interesting in in terms of
applications that is such a great
example it applies to so many other
things as well like retail and like
searching a product it's so hard I I
have stopped shopping at this point
because it's just so hard to find a
thing that I would like because it takes
hours and I'm not a patient person so
it's like being able to just type
something like that um and I know Lance
does that today which I actually use the
lens uh Google for inside Google photos
when you click on the lens button I use
that feature quite a bit because I do
come across pictures where it's like oh
where did you get that code from right
and and then and then it just points you
to at least similar things or if not the
exact same thing that you can buy so
there are some things that already exist
and some amazing use cases that you just
mentioned that would be so cool and
would be so efficient when it comes to
like saving our time and just getting us
to the answers faster
absolutely hey anything else you would
like to add before we wrap it up
I uh so one thing that I would like to
that I would like to to mention is that
we're we're currently working on
um a variety of ml for software
development features that will be uh you
know available to folks externally one
of which is introducing code support
into Bard
um so if folks haven't tried it out yet
there's also uh the ability in barred
not only to generate natural language
but also to generate source code with
syntax highlighting we're adding support
for exporting to collab in addition to a
number of other developer surfaces so if
you generate python code you can click a
button and it'll generate a collab
notebook for you that you can run and
then Bard will also help you debug which
is kind of cool and then one thing you
know we were talking a little bit about
the training data that's used for these
models and how often you know we have
these these properties that generate
code but then they don't necessarily
tell you where it came from and you know
you and I are both really active in the
open source communities it can mean a
lot to say like hey you know this this
snippet of code that was generated it's
very similar to code that's in this repo
with this license so making sure that
the appropriate authors are are
recognized and then also as a user like
if I want to do if I run it want to
write a function to do fubarb as and
somebody has already implemented it it's
much much cooler to be able to go to
that repo you know pip install whatever
library is there and then just use that
instead of having to implement and
maintain something myself
um so so I think those are those are
just a couple of things that people
might want to watch out for go and try
themselves and then send us feedback
because that's the only way we get
better that is so cool and I ended up
trying
um trying to deploy a cloud run
application on uh sample code that Barn
suggested using Python and
um it did a great job so um you know
I'll be continuing to try on features
like that with uh with you know Cloud
users and and how Cloud Architects can
and developers can can utilize Bard as
well very very cool excellent and and we
will never have to write regular
Expressions again
I was always like okay oh my God regular
Expressions run away
exactly so now I'm so relieved that at
least there's somebody who can write
regular expressions and that's not me
awesome
um cool well thank you so much it was so
nice having you it was great being here
thank you for thank you for inviting me
and I'm looking forward to seeing uh to
seeing these features roll out amazing
it's been incredible insightful to hear
all of your thoughts and we look forward
to seeing how AI will continue to shape
the world around us especially in a
developer space because you and I are
both excited about that thank you bye
[Music]